berti manque juste avant l'ouverture du
supermarché
c'est la course pour réapprovisionner
les rayons voit bien en keno le
propriétaire du magasin fait son dernier
tour de piste avant que les clients
arrivent de tout bâtiment depuis plus de
deux semaines ils travaillent 7 jours
sur 7
tâches connexes ramener à la raison ceux
qui sont pris de panique consommatrices
on ne manquera pas de nourriture mais ça
peut arriver que ben oui une circulaire
on épaules produit parce qu'une
circulaire on a décidé il ya peu près de
trois mois et dans tout ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui dans ce cataclysme parce que
c'est un cataclysme
ben oui je peux être pas que le fromage
un tel jeu ne l'est pas pour les
caissières comme anaïs poupart c'est une
autre journée qui commence derrière le
plexiglas pour se protéger serge sur la
ligne n 7 et merci c'est sa nouvelle
réalité et aller vite c'est assez
évident toutes les procédures de
nettoyage si la photo de désinfecter les
caisses à tous les arts on est tous les
paniers
la crise a changé bien des choses dans
son quotidien
les clients sont plus stressés ce jeu le
voile ça m'a fait quand même jeu comme
sensibles à ces choses là j'essaie de
faire preuve de compassion avec les
clients [ __ ] d'être c'est gentil que
possible mais pas toujours facile face
au comportement de certains
consommateurs
c'est passé vite possible ce n'est pas
ça mais il y en ait beaucoup d'échos
vers pas raison une pierre demandé que
voulais pas la laisser entrer avec son
enfant des classes met à crier des
choses comme seul le pied parti en me
soutenant franck pineau veille au grain
hier j'étais sorti une cliente et je lui
ai demandé de venir chez nous parce que
ça peut arriver lors jusque là parce que
c'est un jeu c'est non négociable pour
moi vous manquez de respect de mes
employés n'est plus chez moi sur le
plancher les inquiétudes face au virus
reste à l'esprit des employés c'est
stressant on sait pas à qui on a affaire
les gens y rentrer il y en a qui sont en
maladie avec agen kaspersky moment la
période de quarantaine il ya trop de
gens qui respectent trois heures pour
faire face à la demande
en 24 heures le propriétaire du magasin
a créé dans son sous-sol un service de
commande et de livraison
j'ai engagé à peu près 10% de plus mon
staff j'ai une équipe de 5 personnes en
magasin qui fait les commandes
j'ai une personne qui les prend dans le
bureau j'ai trois livreurs la cadence
s'emballe avec des dizaines de commandes
par jour
les affaires ont beau être bonne les
défis sont énormes
oui à des héros dans les salles
d'urgence oui à des héros dans les
autres dans les hôpitaux mais il y en a
dans toutes les épiceries du québec
126000 héros qui se lève chaque matin au
québec dans l'espoir que les clients
soient plus compréhensif de thé avant
c'était pas vraiment reconnu ces genres
à l'aube en europe c'est ou c'était
comme des mets ces ponts importants
jusqu'à maintenant on est important
depuis monde se rend compte comment que
c'est essentiel de manger on a réinventé
notre métier qu'est ce que ce sera après
je sais pas mais c'est certain que ce
sera différent
fatigué franck hainaut espère pouvoir
prendre un jour de congé
très bientôt ici frédéric arnould radio
canada